en direct depuis tel aviv avec paula
slayer journée pour rt international
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vous êtes donc à tel aviv
on a vu des scènes de liesse de la part
voilà des contres des antilles netanyahu
le changement de gouvernement le départ
de ce premier ministre a provoqué en
tout cas beaucoup de réaction tout à
fait de meilleures solutions à zoug
il avait mentionné attend titre il ya eu
des scènes de liesse parmi les partisans
du centre et de la gauche mais environ
60 % du public à voter pour la droite du
spectre politique
cette partie du spectre politique se
retrouve maintenant dans l'opposition il
ya beaucoup de colère d'incompréhension
au sein de ces partis de droite et les
personnes que j'ai interviewés se
sentent trahis par naftali bennett qui a
quitté la droite et rejoint une
coalition avec la centre et le gauche
afin de devenir le prochain premier
ministre
il serait bien donc la société est très
divisée les images actuelles nous vient
du centre principal de tel aviv des
chanteurs des personnes tu payes entier
se sont rassemblés afin de célébrer ce
nouveau gouvernement sans benyamin
nétanyahou
mais il ya d'autres images dans d'autres
régions du pays où des centaines de
personnes par exemple sont rassemblés
devant le mur de lamentations afin de
prier contre ce nouveau gouvernement
donc ce nouveau ministre se lit vos
gouvernements ont beaucoup de pain sur
la planche
alors avant de s'intéresser à ce nouveau
gouvernement tout de même un mot sur ces
deux ans
deere netanyahu que retiendra-t-on même
si c'est pas facile à résumer que
retiendra-t-on de son bilan on a fait
une équipe de gens se rappelle de lui
comme d'un dirigeant très fort il était
très explicites contre l'iran et quel
que soit le côté du spectre politique de
l'israélien en question tous sont unis
contre l'iran il considère que c'est la
grande menace contre israël
la plupart des israéliens sont heureux
sont satisfaits de ses propos contre le
pouvoir nucléaire iranien et il ne
devrait pas y avoir de changement pour
le gouvernement actuel
il reste une figure contesté au sein de
certains pans de la société il a été
critiqué car il a refusé de passer la
main alors qu'il fait face à un procès
pour corruption c'est le premier
ministre israélien à être impliqué dans
un procès pour corruption alors qu'il
est encore au pouvoir
on l'a accusé d'avoir essayé de faire
jouer sa situation politique afin de
servir ses propres intérêts d'un autre
côté pour être juste on se rappellera
également de lui comme du premier
ministre qui a conclu quatre accords de
normalisation avec quatre pays arabes
tels que le soudan l'arabie saoudite le
bahreïn et le maroc
donc c'est un bilan partagé et en
fonction de à qui on demande la mémoire
est très différente alors naftali
bennett un il est le tout nouveau
premier ministre israélien qui est il
envisagé c'est une personnalité qui
n'est pas connue sur la scène
internationale mais cela fait au moins
une décennie qu'ils travaillent en
politique israélienne il vient du
secteur privé c'est ce qu'on appelle un
self made man
un millionnaire de la tête qui est le
premier ministre orthodoxe de l'histoire
d'israël
c est un juif religieux il a un
passeport américain il parle anglais
très bien et il a commencé sa carrière
politique au service de benyamin
netanyahou il était chef de son bureau
et son aide alors que benyamin
nétanyahou était dans l'opposition
cependant leur relation a été très
instable au cours des années et au cours
des dernières années il a s'est trouvé à
trois postes différents ministériel il a
annoncé son intention d'être candidat au
poste de premier ministre
tout récemment alors que benyamin
nétanyahou essayait encore de l'intégrer
dans sa coalition car il représente une
partie de la société encore plus à
droite que benjamin netanyahu
nathalie baye
comme on a vu ces redirigé vers cette
position du centre et de la gauche afin
de renverser netanyahu alors il a mis
depuis deux ans tout de même
doit-on s'attendre à une elle n'ouvrait
rupture se dit oui sur quel sujet je ne
pense pas qu'il y aura une véritable
rupture
je ne pense pas que ce gouvernement va
durer plus de quelques semaines
peut-être un mois ou deux opus c'est mon
pronostic c'est également le sentiment
généralisé dans le pays
comme je lai évoqué plus tôt l'aft a ni
naftali bennett a fondé une coalition
extrêmement hétéroclites avec huit
partis différents certains de l'extrême
gauche certains de l'extrême droite
comme le parti du maire tony bennett
lui-même dar talib le net par exemple
est opposé à l'idée d'un état
palestinien et le parti arabe est en
faveur de cet état palestinien
naftali bennett est en faveur de
l'expansion des colonies et la gauche et
les partis arabes sont contraints donc
on ne s'attend pas à ce que cette
coalition dure très longtemps et on ne
s'attend pas non plus à ce que elles
prennent des décisions majeures sur des
sujets difficiles car avec de telles
divisions cela l'amènerait directement à
l'effondrement
on pense donc que la coalition se
concentrera sur des sujets économiques
sur la reconstruction qui serait là
après la crise de l'aco vide et sur le
sujet et rania ce ne sont pas les uns
sujets les plus critiques
merci paul à slayer jeunesse pour rt
internationale en direct de tel aviv ce
soir